the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants Studios you know I'm Ryan
cercom Ryan sickler on all your social
media I want to say thank you like I do
every week thank you for supporting this
show thank you for all you do here well
whether you've been here or whether
you're new here and whether and if you
got to have more listen to me I say this
every week patreon the patreon is the
way to go you got all these we sitting
here talking about it with our guests
now all these uh you know flags and red
marks and censored words and everything
not on patreon and the patreon is called
the Honeydew with y'all and it's the
wildest show on patreon it's your
stories and I promise you you've never
heard any anything like it all right and
if you're looking for a new podcast to
listen to my old podcast to crab Feast
which Our Guest today also has an
episode look that has been gone for five
years and the library did 1.1 million
downloads this year it's insane so thank
you for that and I'm telling you it's
all your same favorite guest in
podcasting with different stories you
haven't heard before it's called The
Crab Feast I did it with Jay Larson go
check it out all right make sure you're
subscribed to my new podcast the way
back it's right here on this YouTube
channel um it's a fun new podcast we
just started and um looking forward to
you guys enjoying that one as well all
right um for All Dates all that stuff
ryan.com that's the biz you know what
we're doing over here we're highlighting
the low lights I always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers and
I am very excited to have this guest on
today first time here on the Honeydew
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome Dan
[__] welcome to the Honeydew d thank you
Ryan long overdue bro good to see you
again man same and congrats on all your
success I love it thank you and same to
you brother Ryan's a Ryan's a good dude
the one of the best reputations in the
business as far as just being a solid
guy is that right say there don't no one
has a bad word truly no that's not true
no one that I've talked to seriously all
right um look before we get into
whatever we're going to talk about today
please plug promote everything anything
Dan cumins yeah just uh time suck
podcast if you like deep Dives on
conspiracies uh serial killers
interesting historical figures and more
and uh scared to death if you like
Paranormal kind of campfire ghost
stories uh I do that with my wife trying
and scare her every week and then uh I
got a special trying to get better on
YouTube all right that's it so I was
saying like I know you we you did the
crab Feast great episode back in the day
and time suck was taken off at the time
and it you really popped I was like
motherfucker's doing good good for him
man I love seeing people
like like look at Matt re you got a new
Tik Tok and then boom he takes off I
love seeing people figure out something
yeah and then run with it yep you know
like we're all here for some people take
stand up and parlay it for a uh morning
DJ drive time some get a talk show some
get a this a that a this I love seeing
what uh comedians are able to do me too
I think we're some of the smartest
hardest working Hustlers and cre when it
comes to what has to be out there
there's actors didn't do these podcasts
it
Comics got in sagora comics did all this
yeah all this and and it's fun to to see
how things are morphing and changing
where it's like you know when we started
it was just very traditional you know my
apartment started in my crab fees was in
my apartment kit table oh yeah like we
started there were there weren't all
these options it was just like there was
Gatekeepers there was you do this Open
Mic you hope that you can get to MC you
hope that you can feature you hope that
Comedy Central or one of the late night
people take a liking to you and you know
uh give you air time so you can so you
can get on the morning radio and Poria
or Witchita because you were on The
Tonight Show or whatever I mean it was
like this very linear this is how you
regimented this is way it goes and then
all talk these 20-year-old kid in there
we're not going to be talking about this
everybody the whole time but this
20-year-old kid in ER is a phoenix I let
him open for me yeah um I let him do a
spot and I was like dude you're [__]
really good you're strong you're funny
you're 20 [__] to talk about yeah and um
he's like what advice do you have and I
was like let me tell you what advice I
have when we started we had to bring a
goddamn VHS camera okay record our [__]
then go to a dub house and get a bunch
of made pack them up mail them hoped it
[__] made it hoped that somebody over
there had a VCR that they put it in and
like are you kidding on tonight you can
take your phone pop it up on a set it
can look shitty and you can go out to
you can go home tonight upload it and go
viral tomorrow yep tomorrow so different
it's beyond different and then you're in
the driver's seat you know when you go
viral now it's like you have the power
to to draw you can make deals with clubs
and it's like so many more people you
don't even have to work the clubs you
can just pick any venue that you that
you can make a deal with that your fans
will come to you can skip the whole
comedy industry and just do stand up
outside of it fans come cuz they love
you or whoever it's not the building
there are very few building Comedy Works
Comedy Store the mothership there are
very few buildings that people are like
let's go cuz that place no all right Dan
cumins let's get into you bro I want CU
I really don't know your whole story I
really don't know where you're from
originally your your background you'd
mentioned you had a little bit of a
different upbringing so let's talk about
it little atypical I uh I was born in uh
greville Idaho little town I didn't live
there but but only born there because my
town didn't have a hospital so I was
born in rigin Idaho is that right yep
and Riggins is about 400 people now
little logging used to be a logging town
now it's 400 people what the hell was it
when you were born it was it was a
little more it's it's kind of dying but
not much more it was like 500 wow it was
like it was a high school class oh yeah
my high school I graduated with 23 kids
yeah yep 23 one classroom when I was in
high school easy there had to be more
than 23 some of our typical 35 no [__]
okay so you had to go to another town to
get born yep you either if you if you
grew up in Riggins uh if you weren't
born at home or in the car on the way to
the hospital somewhere which was what my
happened to my aunt you you were born in
greville or McCall they're like both
about an hour away in either direction
along this little Canyon Highway it's
like a it's a it's a very like the town
can't get big there's no room for it
it's in a very steep just River Canyon
in the middle of Idaho yeah so it's not
only small but it's not like it's not
like small Midwest where yes okay you
have 400 people but if you just drive 15
minutes there's a town of 6,000 and then
10 minutes away it's a town of 20,000
like a like one of those peripheral
small towns It's a Small Town not near
anything you have to drive a long way to
get to other tiny towns like it's super
remote and because of the because it was
so remote you know like cable TV all
those kind of things it was not a
priority because there was not enough
financial incentive for those things to
exist there so we were like 10 15 years
behind technology wise is that right oh
yeah like way behind you're how old now
I'm 46 so when did you guys get cable
out there not when I lived there are you
serious you have it didn't exist yeah no
[__] we we had the the thing that you
could get was an illegal satellite TV
configuration which uh there wasn't like
dish or those places but what people do
it cracks me up looking back that I
guess just no one cared about regulating
this you would get a massive if your
family had the money you get a massive
satellite dish like like a NASA type
dish giant thing on a huge you know 10
foot by 10 foot concrete slab and then
you would get this thing called the
blackbox the Scrambler and it would give
you all of the channels and I don't know
how it was configured but so you either
had no channels or all of the channels
but if you didn't have one of those then
you had to depend on the airway
and my grandpa was actually one of the
ones that put this reflector up on this
Mountaintop on the uh edge of town
because it's so down in this Canyon that
the airwaves wouldn't reach it so they
like hiked up like dragged this thing up
yeah like your grandfather's responsible
for TV in that town and then you get
like three channels that's great or
three or four three you I'll take it
over hell yeah it was yeah
really very different so very limited
like you're separated from the rest of
the world and you can't even connect
with them Tech wise and are you um an
only child no I have what a sister older
or younger younger okay yeah is five and
a half years younger okay what about
your parents were they together no uh
together when I was born okay and then
when I was I don't know two or three my
dad moved to anguage Alaska he was a l
oh [__] okay and then he went up there
to work with his brothers in
construction a couple of his brothers
had moved there and then my mom and him
followed him so when I was like three or
so like that we went to Alaska as well
and so then I went to kindergarten first
second half a third grade in Anchorage
my sister was born when I was like in
kindergarten then my parents split up
Dad stayed in Anchorage and then we went
back to Riggins to live with my
grandparents okay so let me ask you this
question because this is interesting to
me Anchorage is not the biggest city in
the world either but but is it an is it
an upgrade and Tech and everything
compared to where you just left in Idaho
oh yeah I mean I you know it's like I
was pretty little then but I have
memories of like you know you're not
supposed to watch HBO you know like like
that kind of stuff like we we had it
yeah yeah uh and and I remember like you
know we had a just wild me to think that
Alaska you think this frozen tundra is
is dialed in more than that little town
I remember we had Fred Myers uh we had
Taco Time like around us you know like
and then we went back to rins and just
nothing like there's no fast food there
really nope there's no chains so still
uh still yeah for a little while um
after put Papa John's in that
[__] you're going to be rich bro
you just should franchise a Papa John in
there tomorrow what a weird thing too
like nobody supports it's a weird local
mentality too like no one shops local
even though it's like this tiny little
town what people will do is they'll
they'll go to Costco they'll go 2 and 1
half hours away is it that far yeah
like this Lewis and Idaho or two hours
between depends on how you drive two two
and a half go to Le and Idaho Lewis and
clarkon go to the Costco everybody has
like a deep freeze like my mom does this
and then just stocks up for like a month
or two worth of food and then when one
of the local businesses dies again
they're like oh man just Town's dying
I'm like yeah because none of you shop
at the local places right like I can't
believe anything still exists there
outside house your parents are still
there uh my mom
this is so ridiculous but my stepdad so
my mom gets married again when I'm like
I don't know 10 or 11 to this guy Tim my
stepdad still Tim Hinkley well Tim had
lived in whitebird which is even smaller
than Riggins it's like a hundred people
uh 30 miles away he moves to
rigin and then he convinces my mom uh
when I was like at the end of high
school to move back to White Bird
because Riggins seriously is too many
people for him
yeah he didn't like all the neighbors he
didn't like he just too neighbors
there's 400 people this
[__] so that's a
parade so now they're in white bird and
not even in White Bird they're like just
outside of white bird so you really got
to want to be first of all you better
love the [__] out of your partner if
that's all if that's all all the time
all the time right yep and you really
got to want love to live out there like
that huh yeah you got to love the
outdors yeah and be isolated is are you
playing sports or anything like that is
there any organized sport what like what
the [__] are you doing there was sports
but not a lot of them we didn't have
baseball um for like have fields or just
not enough people to coach field but not
enough people and and also it's like
it's small but you have to drive so far
to get to other communities it's like
you got to go to a half an hour to
another town called New Meadows is about
the same size as us and then another
half hour p so there's like and it's
kind of like a dangerous like these
little Highway Canyon roads and so it
was tricky to um to get to other places
our school didn't have baseball but we
did have like American Legion ball for
like two years and then but then that
went away it wasn't enough people uh we
had basketball
track um volleyball all through the
schoolb no soccer um and we had
eight-man football eight man yeah and
everybody played offense and defense
yeah yeah
yeah and you know what's crazy we had a
first round draft pick well after my
time there what do you mean Leighton
vanderesh for the Dallas Cowboys played
in rigin nah how the hell did they find
him Kudos so the scouts on that guy he
went from Salmon River High where I went
to high school uh I'll have to tell you
about our mascot so inappropriate and
then went to walked on to boisey state
if I remember right the
blue Turf right and then played so well
there that he got attention but yeah it
came out of I mean I don't know him or
anything it was after my time but like
yeah it came out of little old rigin no
[__] all right Sam River savages savages
is what you guys were uh our painted on
the gym wall uh American Indian guy
wildeyes back with a tomahawk race like
he's about to murder people The Savage
to this day it's still that yeah there
ain't nobody telling them to change and
not the most inappropriate mascot in our
league who's the most inappropriate uh
or or maybe they're just maybe they're
out of our league but we would play them
but orino Idaho which is a little
bigger their mascot is the maniac I
believe still it was growing up and I
last I checked it still was orino
Maniacs yeah and who what represents the
maniac uh uh a crazy eyed hair going
everywhere and I I believe I think they
changed the painting maybe to act like
it wasn't what they were doing but when
I grew up it was a like a dude in a
straight jacket it was like a maniac and
next to the high school was one of the
State Mental Hospitals n yep
yeah the high school the maniacs and Mas
just get come yeah get a do mascot every
night yeah and they tried to say when
they they got you know people later got
mad about it and they're like no no no
it has nothing to do with the state
hospital uh they acted like it was just
some announcer said oh they're playing
so hard on the court they're playing
like a bunch of maniacs and that's all
it was it's like no I I saw the painting
it's clearly a nod that is Joe over
there yeah that's that's Jo
Joe yeah but yeah tiny so tiny little
sports sports teams but we did have we
did have sports but but other than that
I mean what would you do a lot of kind
of like dinking around in the woods do
you have four-wheelers what do you have
out there not when I was growing up my
mom does now four-wheelers it was mostly
like God I mean just walking then yeah
just bike riding playing hoops at the
you know little outdoor Court in town or
just um uh swimming in the river like
outdoor stuff I mean some people it was
normal back then to like you know just
walk out in the woods with a I don't
know 22 rifle and shoot a squirrels like
real backwood stuff yeah yeah my like my
stepdad like I have so many memories of
weekends him and his buddies was very
typical they at the time they would just
like we' go camp on the weekends so
we're already living in a small town and
then we'd leave the small town go way
further out in the woods camp and it was
basically just a bunch of dudes drinking
Keystone lights and shooting at small
creatures like they would spend an
entire afternoon shooting at groundhogs
and if you're like if you ask like well
why why are you doing that why not it's
just something to do yep yep so how
often are you seeing your dad then when
your mom you said your mom followed him
up but then left right so so what age do
you stop seeing your dad regularly at
least uh so I I was third grade so I
think I was eight okay uh eight or nine
but I think eight and then I don't and
then for a few
years I I just don't see him much he
he's he's up in Alaska we're down there
I saw him maybe like once or twice a
year weekend or something like that talk
to him on the phone usually once a week
and then he moves down to Arizona and
then I I don't know seventh or eighth
grade is when I first spent like a
summer or half the summer with him so
then I'd spend half the summer with my
dad and then he moved to Las Vegas and
when I was a freshman in high school so
the summer before freshman year in high
school I went down to spend part of the
summer with my dad and then just didn't
come back I I like I was kind of a dad
dad's boy and uh wanted to spend more
time with him so then I went to live in
Las Vegas my freshman and sophomore year
of high school and so then went to a a
high school where there was like 650
kids in my class and it was just huge
culture shock talk about that yeah you
went to Vegas went to Vegas why Vegas
that's where my dad was living for
construction so you just and so you want
to be with him be with wanted to be with
him and that's where he was living and
so uh my sister now my sister and I kind
of split so she's living with my mom
primarily I live with my dad primarily
and it was we were living in this anchor
Village Apartments off of like rainbow
and uh Durango it's been so many years
and I went to uh Bonanza High School
what was there Mas what's I don't
remember Actually I don't even know what
their Mas is Cowboy I proba Cowboy or
something but it was that was like my
introduction like we had kids at the
school who supposedly were like in gangs
like the Bloods and stuff and I would
see like crazy about that dude you're
going from 100 kids to or your
graduating class was 23 you said to this
yeah and our our high school there had
about I don't know 20 24 25 2600 kids
something like that and it was huge
culture shock cuz I was like very much
and we were poor too like both Dad and
Mom very poor so I'm like getting my
clothes at like flea markets and stuff
but that was the first time I knew I was
poor because in Riggins everybody was
poor tell me about that yeah so it's
like and then all of a sudden in my
freshman year High School uh you know I
distinctly felt like for the first time
like a massive Outsider it's like you
know I got these these kids with their
Zeke cavari yeah and all that kind of
stuff or Hugo Boss or whatever and I'm
like wearing like a Bart Simpson [__]
flea market t-shirt and
uh and like because we Liv next to this
kind of Rich area it was like our
apartment complex but then next to this
area called The Lakes where it's like an
artificial lakes and these mansions and
those kids went to my same school but
then also kids from like rougher areas
went
so it was like the first time I'd been
around like clicks and I didn't really
fit in any of them and I I'm also
guessing everyone in your town in Idaho
was white yep Anchorage maybe not for
one kid maybe Anchorage not so much but
in Idaho it's
like like you would have maybe one
family like um we had one literally one
Asian girl in town in the whole town in
my class Jenny beo her dad was Japanese
her mom was white she lived with her
white mom and Riggins so it was like
literally just Jenny and then uh uh what
was it uh Garcia's it was like we had
one family Joey I remember his first
name who was Hispanic like literally one
Hispanic family and that was it I feel
like as far as ethnic diversity and then
you know Las Vegas it was you know
everything say everything Latino Asian
white black everybody's out there yeah
yeah yeah and I I uh so yeah so I went
from like being kind of a popular kid I
guess in Riggins as far as everyone's
kind of popular there for the most part
but uh one of the more popular I was
kind of like a little
played basketball uh baseball you know
when it was going anything I could and
then in and was good for there for like
for rigin go to Vegas and I am beyond
like not even GNA like ride the bench
like not a whiff of playing on any of
the teams not that's what I wanted to
say about the guy that got drafted crazy
the leap he made that's what I'm saying
like you think in a 100 people like even
the top guy and then you put him it's
it's like the Heisman Trophy winner in
college you put him in the NFL sometimes
they don't even do [__] yep best college
guy can't even be anything in the NFL it
happens so for you for that guy to go
from there and be like yeah it is insane
to not be intimidated and and just
speaks to his like raw athletic ability
yes I did not have that blessed yeah oh
totally totally uh and then I just
became kind of a delinquent so really I
was going to say how' you fit in so you
become a delinquent so I so I don't
really have many friends uh and then I
and then looking back kind of like
analyzing myself I don't know that I
would have thought this at the time but
like I went there to spend time with my
dad my dad was busy with construction
and just like with my stepmom and and
just not like a real interactive dad at
that time and so looking back I think I
was pretty pissed about it and so I'm
just kind of stewing in my room and then
you know like uh I meet this kid named
Chris and he's just like Anarchy uh he
lives in the apartment actually was
condos this complex of condos next to
our apartment complex situation and his
mom single mom no dad around and his mom
is usually at her boyfriend's house
every weekend so if I would stay the
night at Chris's on the weekend we had
free reain to do whatever we wanted and
whatever we wanted uh tended to revolve
around trying to make explosives
and and burning a lot of [__] yeah
burning [__] so we were like starting
fires we were break he had a lock pick
set we were breaking into places
breaking into cars for real oh yeah
trying to blow [__] up no I was the only
I it was Chris me uh Russ and I can't
remember this fourth kid but like out of
all of us they all had records and I
like barely avoided getting caught every
time places what kind of places like
businesses [__] craziest place we broke
into that I could have gotten in a lot
of trouble we had these [__] all
these convoluted plans we played
basketball at this either grade school
or Junior High like half mile down the
road and we came up with this plan we
were going to break into that into the
school the school M take computers and
then Pawn the computers for money for
for video games just some [__] dumb
15 16 year old plan and so one night
we're we're staying at Chris's place we
had a Russ was supposed to be our
getaway
driver and uh he drops us off we push
this dumpster over to the edge of the
building climb up the building there's
an access thing on the roof we're able
to like break that get in and then we're
able to like break door locks it was
like the the handles that you grab that
are the horizontal the floor and if you
just stood on it basically and pushed
all your weight you could kick it and
break it and get into these places and
then we walk out I don't know alarms are
going off we walk out like they're going
off for real M and you're walking we
walk out like with computers with
computers in our arms but you know it's
middle of the night kind of a quiet
residential we still thought we could
get out of well then some security guard
has you know been alerted and is coming
to our place and you know gets out of
the car but he's like I don't know 5060
70 ft away put the computers down
yelling at us you know walk over here
and I tell Chris it's like like that
time in in Vegas where we were at there
would be like a block of developed you
know track houses Apartments whatever
and then next to it a full block of just
desert so totally dark so there was like
this grid of you could just kind of like
weave through these darker areas and be
a little sneaky and I was like no man
let's just go well Chris thought he
could talk his way out of it he sets his
stuff down walks over to the security
guard I stand in the darkness and just
yell for like a minute of like [__]
push him [__] go push him [__] that
guy he doesn't I do and so I actually
made it back to Chris's condo and then I
just stayed at his place by myself that
night Russ got spooked and never went
picked us up he just [__] left us Yep
this [__] get driver get away
driver gone so but there was like
incidents like that so Chris got in
trouble yeah didn't me out no nobody
ever ratted me out but I had like little
things like that yeah we had we had a
ton of just the dumbest how how do we
not get caught the craziest one that I
should have gotten caught for we had
another really dumb plan where we were
going to steal bicycles at another
apartment complex across the street from
Chris's kto and middle the day uh and I
had I was I was such a dork I was into
rollerblades so I had rollerblades it
was Chris and one of Chris's friends I
can't remember his name this other dude
we were GNA get those guys bikes and
then they're gonna bike downtown to this
uh like computer game store I'm going a
rollerblade we're g to uh steal [__]
from there God it was the [__]
dumbest plan what was I think yeah we're
going to steal [__] from there and then
take just ride our bikes back and stuff
like that return them to whoever we
stole them from and then just go play
these games we didn't make it very we
never made it very far we were very
unsuccessful on all of these plans we
had we go middle of the day it's like
these uh big apartment buildings where
there's maybe eight units on a side and
so there'll be like you walk into and
then two little I guess entrances where
you walk into an entrance and there's an
apartment on your left it's like
two-story apartment on your right or you
can go up the stairs one on your left
one on your right and then but all of
those have balconies and with like
screen doors and stuff so if anybody's
in there they can just be looking out to
see who's coming in this main entrance
middle of the day don't even check to
see who's there there's like two bikes
next to one of the doors Chris and this
other guy just walk in just grab
straight up [__] grab these bikes
start walking them out and then the guys
were home like they just saw them
walking away with their bikes I'm like
being my little [__] rollerblader in
the parking lot
doing circles waiting for and these two
guys come out and they're jacked they're
like dud in theirs and they're like what
the [__] that's are [__] bikes and
now Chris and this other guy like throw
the bikes down they start running well
I'm on Rollerblades and I'm
rollerblading with one of the other guys
who's running now during this down this
like to next to him so I'm in front at
first like I'm doing great I'm leaving
him in the dust I'm [__]
rollerblading way in front of him but I
ain't never heard anybody tell a story
about K away a roller
blade this is I wish I had visual of
this just for my own memories like a
like a video in my mind you're a short
shorts and a half
shirt oh it's probably not far off so
I'm [__] I'm rollerblading and at the
edge you know in the desert there would
be these big like I guess what where the
water could drain off into the desert
out of the parking lots so you these big
concrete things where you rollerblade
and then I made it to the end so it's
like a wall like a 6ot you know concrete
kind of block wall and we get cornered
like there's nowhere to go me and this
other dude on foot well he's on foot I'm
on roller blades this other guy chasing
us he's on foot we climb over the wall
throw ourselves well now it's one of
those roller blade you they're heavy
dude they're I pulled myself over well
then check this [__] out I Dro myself on
the other side I have a full block of
desert now now it's just Sage Brush I'm
going [__] roll
I'm like you're
alling so I'm running as fast as I
[__]
canes and now and now the dude who I was
way ahead of well he [__] passes me
cuz he's on foot and so and then the
other dude that's chasing us jumps over
the wall and now I have like this crazy
adrenaline where I just have to make it
to the sidewalk and if I can make it to
the sidewalk I'll [__] beat him I
wish I had video of how [__] hard I
was running in these heavy roller blades
and then how I did make
it oh and I was so happy as I'm [__]
roller blading down the sidewalk like I
barely made it to the sidewalk in front
of him but then I was gone like I was
pretty it's like so many close calls you
got away on roller blades dude can you
imine like there was a busy Street next
to us I just picture somebody my age now
driving and seeing this skinny ass kid
on roller
blades this big Jack dude chasing him
if I could just get him before he hits
that pain oh he would beat the [__] out
of he would beat the [__]
out and so many incidents like that of
almost getting
annihilated oh God rightfully so by
people I done shitty things to oh [__]
God damn it hilarious according to the
CDC fewer men than women meet the
minimum daily intake recommendations for
fruits and vegetables and men are more
likely to overvalue exercise and
undervalue nutrition enter ritual a
multivitamin scientifically developed
for men to help fill nutrient gaps in
their diets I've listen I've been using
ritual for years all right they get
mailed to my home uh they come in little
capsules got those little balls in there
too it's hard to eat well all the time
when you're running around on tour doing
podcast all that stuff ritual I've been
taking it for years I I threw away all
the other multivitamins I used to go get
at the store I've been using ritual for
years I 100% believe in them it's a
science back multivitamin for men 18 and
over with high quality and traceable key
ingredients and clean bioavailable forms
10 key nutrients in two delayed release
capsules per day designed to dissolve
later in the small intestine an optimal
place to absorb nutrients and it's
gentle on an empty stomach with a minty
Essence in every bottle that helps make
taking your multivitamins actually
enjoyable essential for men is a quality
multivitamin from a company you can
actually trust get 40% off your first
month for a limited time at ritual.com
honey do this offer is only available
through January 31st start your ritual
or add essential for men to your
subscription today that's ritual.com
honeydo for 40% off the farmers dog was
founded by two dog lovers who decided to
reimagine pet food from the ground up
the results of switching your dog from
kibble to Fresh Food can seem like magic
when a senior dog starts acting like a
puppy again or the pickiest of eaters
can't wait for dinner time you might
think some spells were cast but the
farmer's dog doesn't use any sorcery or
secret ingredients to make their fresh
food just science it is developed by
vets nutritionally balanced and made
from real healthy ingredients to human
food safety standards it's the best
option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble it's not canang
goo it's just real healthy food not only
that it's also preor specifically for
your dog based on their unique
nutritional needs this makes it easy to
help your dog maintain their ideal
weight which is one of the biggest
indicators of a healthy life it doesn't
matter if your dog is young or old it's
always the right time to begin investing
in their health helping you live more
healthy happy and full years together
get 50% off your first box of fresh
healthy food at the farmers.com
honeydo plus you get free shipping just
go to
thefarmersdog.com honeydo to get 50% off
that's thefarmersdog.com
honeydo the Honeydew is sponsored by
better help around new years's every
year we're getting obsessed with how to
change ourselves instead of taking time
to just expand on what we're already
doing right maybe you finally organized
a part of your space and maybe you want
to tackle another or maybe you're taking
your supplements every morning and now
you want to add more to your routine too
therapy helps you find your strength so
you can ditch extreme resolutions and
make changes that really stick all right
I'm a I'm a big believer in therapy I go
to therapy I still I just recently had a
session just a talk you know sometimes
just need somebody to listen and help
you out and I'm telling you if you're at
that point or even thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule you just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge celebrate the progress you've
already made visit betterhelp.com
honeydo today to get 10% off your first
month that's better help
hp.com honeydo now let's get back to the
D okay so if you say you're graduating
classes so then you go back why do you
go back it was the
weirdest I guess because my dad had cont
you like it there did you like living
with your dad I mean more than that's my
question did you enjoy it not what I
thought it was going to be I I love my
dad and I have a good relationship now
uh but we had definitely some like
rougher years and part of it was like no
it was not my my stepmom was a
psychopath oh he remarried as well okay
and check this this is the craziest as a
parent now and again I love my dad now
like we're good so I don't want to throw
my dad in the bus but I just can't
believe he did this looking back so he's
a divorced guy before I moved to Vegas
two
kids he meet this blackjack dealer at
one of the casinos downtown Vegas they
uh they get married two weeks after they
meet two weeks and be and in that
interim Pro during that two weeks she
tells him not only does she not want to
have kids I don't like kids and so she
know he had two before they got married
and these [__] idiots so he marries a
woman as a guy with two kids who does
not like kids just straight up and she
marries him both of them [__] idiots
marries a guy who she knows has two kids
and so she was not Overjoyed when I went
to live with them and it was just so it
was it was not a great like you know
living with somebody who actively does
not like you but you're a high schooler
is that considered kid still for her
just in general period not not some
toddler she had to help take care of or
she doesn't really even need to be a mom
a mom no and she was kind of like you
know absent she just wasn't a good
person like they ended up getting
divorced later but she just like there
was I don't know what the [__] the sex
must have been amazing must have must
have been amazing because I don't know
other than that like what he saw in her
like no nobody does were they together
for a while uh they were together for
about 10 15 years so quite a while I got
to say off of a twoyear oh my God two
weeks I mean it made two weeks sorry yes
thank two weeks to 15 years even even
unhealthy as it was good 15 years but
I'm saying they [__] they kept it
together some oh paid for big time uh
but but then randomly so okay so we're
down there for two years well he's you
know not making a ton in construction
and in Vegas at that time he just um
feels like they're never going to be
able to kind of get ahead down there and
he did like in rigin he moved all around
he was like a pastor's son his dad took
various gigs at different Pentecostal
churches and so they moved around a bit
but they like he liked Riggins where he
met my mom still had friends there like
that area the the country just thought
it was beautiful he's a big hunter
outdoors guy and randomly was just kind
of looking back at the area and so 12 13
miles outside of rigin is a little
Community called Pinehurst and I mean I
don't know 15 20 people live there
that's it it's like a gas station it's
like two families yeah a gas station a
church and then just a couple families
like a [__] so it's not a town it's just
like there's these little communities
along the river he finds a piece of
property there that is super cheap and
just uh end of my sophomore year is like
Hey we're going back to that area and it
was like like if he would have moved 10
miles further away from rigin I would
have been a different school system I
would have been like with new meows so I
ended up just happening to to go back to
my original school so you now you're
reuniting with people you already knew
and that was super fun so then junior
senior year it's like yeah I didn't want
to stay in rigin forever but it was just
nice to have like my old friends and
stuff so that was good uh but then it
was just a weird living situation
because I didn't get my driver's license
before we left I missed driver's
training in Idaho so I had a full year
when we got back where I'm just kind of
stuck out in Pinehurst and uh it's funny
I showed my mother-in-law she was
curious about where I grew up we drove
to like the the area where I was a
little kid in Riggins and then took her
out to Pine she literally cried at like
how sad it was she now right now and it
was worse then that's what I'm saying
she's crying today she's like I can't
believe you got out of here cuz it's
like rural poverty
my [__] room my Junior and Senior
year of high school was essentially a
shed like I basically lived in a shed
because there was like the main house
which was a one bedroom one bath one bed
one bath for your mom dad that was for
stepmom and dad sister yep and then
sister still at Mom's most of the time
well there was this oh wait this is when
you went back this when I go back okay
so now there's this outer building on
the other side of the property that was
no real insulate I it was built like a
shed it was like concrete floor and no
real insulation in the walls and no uh
sink I mean we had a toilet out there
but that was it it was just like a it
was like a [__] room where you would
you would feel like you take a hostage
like uh like some [__] Sex Dungeon
where you're going to trap somebody and
like hey you can [__] in the toilet
that's all you got you got to stay in
this locked room that was the bathroom
and then there was just uh kind of two
rooms there was a wall in between but it
had a doorway but no door you never put
a door in so there was just like a
curtain separating my sister's room and
my room no like AC heat none of that and
that that's where I lived fresh or
Junior Senior Year damn and and just out
in the middle of [__] nowhere like so
then when do you get out when do you
decide to move out of there uh after I
graduated senior I luckily no I had to
uh I worked for my dad in construction
that summer to save money but um just
because I needed money for for college
and I worked at the grocery store as
soon as I got a I turned 17 I was able
to get a license I got a little truck
then I worked at the grocery store in
town to save money and then uh and then
I got a scholarship or a series of
little scholarships and grants to
Gonzaga and did you and that's what got
me out of there okay yeah so I was Co
college for me was less about like oh I
got this plan if I'm going to do this
and then I'm going to get this kind of
job it was just I just [__] need to
get out of here and college was the the
way to do it and my family was very
supportive of that too they they wanted
me to go to
college so what is your relationship
like with your sister good yeah really
good so was it did you did you two like
enjoy getting back together when you
moved back yeah yeah for sure I mean
she's five and a half years younger so
at that age it's a pretty big gap you
know but um but now was really good like
I like try to look out for her and you
know kind of Mentor her a little bit I
guess when I got to college and and then
as adults we become like really close
you mentioned your mom remarried too was
he a good dude yeah he's a good dude
like good to you and stuff unlike the
Stepmom yeah yeah he's great and and Tim
is uh still by they still together oh
they are yep he's a solid dude okay yeah
super chill yeah big uh big big gun guy
I like I like guns you know uh a fair
like whatever it's fun to shoot him
listen if you live out there you better
be a [__] gun person you don't just
have people you got animals you got all
kinds of [__] out there yeah yeah we did
a little hunting and stuff my dad's
really big into that but my stepdad he
was a like a logging equipment mechanic
and yeah just a cool dude it's a job you
don't hear all
I know right yeah what your mom do she
worked at uh when we first moved back
she worked like the pizza place and a
variety of little places and then she
got a job at the grocery store kind of
doing their bookkeeping and then she
went from there to like there was like
One Bank in town so it was a pretty like
coveted job because it had
benefits uh you know decent pay and then
so she worked as a a checker at the at
the bank or teller I
guess yeah then my my grandma my my
grandparents my mom parents my Grandma
Betty and grandport they were like the
real glue that were like provided the
most stability so no matter where I was
I always had a super good relationship
with them they local as well they lived
in Riggins we lived with them when we
first moved back from Alaska my grandp
had built a series of little rental
houses and so actually the places we
live with my mom were places he owned
okay and super helpful to his two
daughters and they both were and uh but
like he worked at The Sawmill before it
before it burnt to the ground and wasn't
built and my grandma worked at the post
office so they had like good jobs for
that little town yeah post office that's
a government job in that town hell yeah
so she worked at the post office for
like 30 something years so you had a
little bit of family but you have no
cousins or anything like that that you
know of up there just you and your
sister yeah cousins in other little
towns an hour hour and a half away but
no nobody else in town yeah were you an
introvert or were you just forced to be
an introvert at first and then you
realize you're not when you get to Vegas
like what were you like like growing up
there's not are you spending a lot of
alone time yeah but I'm I think I've
always I've always been an introvert you
know where it's like it's weird like you
know I love conversations like this but
as far as like you want me to come hang
out at some big G together like no part
of that has ever sounded fun to me
really like when I was hammered in
college I'm an extroverted introvert
yeah yeah I can turn it on for moment FR
crowds and yeah I don't want to go
[__] hang out at the anniversary
party or whatever I'm not interested
yeah me too me too and so I I I think it
helped honestly my imagination I just
like you know read a lot of books uh
played a lot of like stuff you know just
games by myself like when I was little
it was GI Jo's and that where you're
building scenarios and all this stuff
and then in high school when I came back
you know got into like Dungeons and
Dragons for a little bit but just um a
lot of time to think and a lot of time
just to I don't know Daydream and stuff
I guess so I I do think that shaped me
somewhat yeah yeah I want to talk um I
just want to switch gears for a second
cuz we were talking before we recorded
about you know you start to get a little
bit of success and then yeah you got to
keep working right we all have that like
I don't know I just come from that it's
F I just saw this clip the other day
that was like yeah it's like um I worked
five jobs at one point wow you know I I
never worked less than three you know
doing something and I was always broke
right and then you hear all these other
people I'm working three jobs they're
always broke and I was like there's got
to be a smarter not harder way right and
when you just come from that you know I
I'm very blue collar background and come
from that just work and you don't even
know why it's go to college and you'll
make something
yourselft I'm just supposed to go to
this University and then magically I'm
going to make something myself like it
was that's what everyone the answer to
success was college and I no longer feel
that way at all um I I'll go back and
forth my daughter's mother on this cuz
she's like are you going to save for a
college fund and I'm like no no she's
like but what if she wants to go to
college I was like I'll deal with it
once she wants to go to college like I
had nothing yeah so just because we have
I don't want to just throw M well then
you could just give her the [__]
$40,000 I'm like yeah I'm good on that
I'm good on that I'm going to use that
[__] money you know yeah yeah
yeah so you actually hit a little bit of
burnout is that right yeah for the first
time because like you I was raised you
know very you know poor and and like
blue collar and same thing like in high
school you know as soon as I could drive
I'm I'm working before I go to school
doing like started seventh grade started
working in seventh grade like when I was
in when I was in grade school and stuff
I mowed a bunch of Lawns that was like
how I get some extra money and then uh
snow for people you got to we didn't
have enough snow there right really yeah
it's like it's in a weird little
microclimate if you go uh half an hour
in any either direction a Idaho and it's
just [__] yeah but where we yeah not
much there but yeah little you know do
this do that work for my dad go to job
sites you know construction then work
you know the the before school after
school when I got to college always had
a job and like you said usually two
never had more than three but I would
have like multiple jobs you know got out
of uh school had my fulltime job it's
kind of like a lowlevel counselor type
uh position but then also worked at a
gym always working lots of hours and
then just carried that mentality into
comedy you know doing standup and then
trying to like uh you know spec scripts
or uh working in reality television as a
consultant produc while doing standup
while hosting this other thing just
always doing a lot of things stand up
always present doing 10 other [__]
things Y and then carry that into
podcasting launching all these podcasts
but then yeah but I also do standup so
you know when you're offered like tour
dates especially once you start to kind
of sell some tickets you're like oh man
now I'm after 15 years I'm finally
making more than 1500 a week you know
doing this and saying yes to all that
and just in the habit of just always
saying yes yep uh there's an opportunity
I'll take it and then pretty soon I'm
working legitimately 70 plus hours a
week every week and then that just
becomes normal of like never having a
day off uh even on vacation wife kids
they'll go do something I work half days
and then I'm hanging out with the fam in
the evenings and that just like became
our like normal way of life and then it
was just this last year that I just
started to get like so tired and just
yeah just really ex but I but I didn't
even interpret it as that at first I
just felt like depressed and I'm like
why am I not enjoying all these things
that I've been enjoying when did you
when did it like finally click like man
I've just been cuz cuz for a while you
just get in that work Mode work work
when did it hit you where you were like
hey it was when my son went to college
it was like I think I had this end goal
like because then I got divorced you
know later and really struggled for the
few years after the divorce like
worrying about am I going to be able to
help my kids go to college my ex-wife
she's killing it in the corporate world
great job am I going to be like the dead
beat dad and not be able to help all
these things are coming up in my head
like worried about like am I going to be
a version of kind of how my dad was for
a certain period and not be able to help
and that was like a big fear of mine so
then once I started making some money
I'm like oh cool I'll be able to like
help my kids like I wanted to and then
that became my whole focal point was
getting the kids to college and my wife
and I mov back to cordelane to be close
to my ex like we didn't move there
because we wanted to live back in okay
so you were married once right and got
divorced got divorced you had two kids
two kids yep my son and my daughter
moved to LA flying them back and forth
trying to make something here wow you
know so it's tough so so it's like you
know you're when you're not working
you're also getting on planes to make
sure your present father all these
things well if you want to be a good
father totally know very much could
could have been a dead could have been a
piece of [__] but wanted to be a good
dad and uh and then we moved to
cordelane thinking that was going to
[__] our careers it definitely [__] my
wife's career she worked in uh film and
TV production said goodbye to that so
then all our Focus became just on the
kids up in cordelane and making sure
that work making sure the sacrifice we
took so wait you actually did the
opposite of your father you married a
woman that liked kids yep good for you
oh that was yeah good for after that way
to not Replay that out oh my god when
she first met him I remember being so
nervous cuz that was super into her can
I ask you how long you waited before you
introduced your new wife to your
children it wasn't super long because
when we started dating the kids were
with me for the summer and they were
about to go back and so I I wanted just
to test the waters so we all went to a
Dodgers game and that was like the
introduction we go to a Dodgers game
with you know with my friend and I was
just curious how the kids would take to
her and I was super nervous because if
it didn't click I was like well then
that that's it it's over but I but I was
like really into her and thank God like
they adore her like she's a super Versa
yep and vice versa she's very very uh
nurturing she worked at like like a what
like the synagogue daycare and stuff so
she was like worked with kids and liked
that and was a nanny for a couple
families uh early on when she was
getting into production so I knew that
she was good with kids but you don't
know that's going to translate to yours
so luckily that works but then like so
Lindsay and I so my wife and I's focal
point becomes we're living here for the
kids we're busting our ass for the kids
and everything is like getting them to
college and then when my son when I
dropped him off in college and come home
it was like the most unexpected
depression just hit like so hard like
you know miss him a ton I was going to
say is you're an empty nester yeah well
I had one kid halfway and then but it
was also like I didn't realize that I
crossed this Finish Line where I'm like
well I was just focus on just getting
them to college now one's there and
we're doing okay financially it's like
this thing I'm like oh yeah I'm not poor
anymore and then it was like and I go
right back into the grind of the 70
hours a week but then I had this
lingering feel of like why are you still
doing this like why are you still
working this many hours and this
awareness of you only have three years
left with Monroe and then she's going to
be in college like you know how that
hits now don't you want to like be
around even more because now you can and
then that that voice is just kind of in
the background and then I have this
special come out on YouTube and we're
doing these press for it so I'm doing
the podcasting uh the tour dates flying
to New York flying to LA taking these
trips and when I was in New York like a
month or two ago Lindsay was my wife was
trying to get me to uh come up with a
tour name and she's talking about hey we
got to make plans we got to get these
things uh together as far as when you're
going to announce certain things on the
podcast and I've been dragging my feet
on that stuff and she just said she's
like honestly she goes I don't think you
want to do it I was like what she's like
every time I bring it up you want to
push things off and you don't seem
excited do you want to do this and and I
just like thought for a second I'm like
I don't know and and then she said if I
you know she's like you don't need my
permission but she's like you don't have
to and just so you know I'm not going to
be upset I'm not going to care that
we're going to lose that money she's
like I care about you I want to make
sure that you're healthy she's like I'm
worried about you and there have been
months of people being like hey I'm
worried about how much you're working
yeah they were saying and in the family
like my dad and stuff years of people
being like you're working too much and
like you it's like I always prided
myself on that blue collar work ethic
and that was like how you have kind of
worth and value is you're a hard worker
that's like the best thing you can be in
life is a hard worker a hustler a
hustler a grinder so much respect for
that and now I'm having more people
being like yeah but you don't have to
grind this hard and then when Lindsay
was like you don't need to do this and
I'm like you you promise you're not
gonna be mad and she's like no I'm like
I don't think I want to do it and then
that led to this domino effect where
that I fired my agency
uh cancel this tour uh also cancel some
of the bonus content we were doing on
patreon for time suck because it was it
was just a lot it was like a lot of
weekly things explain that to the fans
and I'm kind of panicking internally
like I know I need to do this but in my
brain I think all the fans are going to
go away people are going to think I'm a
[__] huge [__] uh the concert
promoter will never want to work with me
again because I'm a [__] baby like
all these old school Tough Guy voices
being like up you're a [__] [__] and
uh now you're being exposed for that and
it's all going to go away nope everybody
was cool everybody was like good job man
you got to take care of yourself uh
agent left the agency like still with
him con promoter was like whenever
you're ready to come back we support you
we love you actually Andrew Dorfman one
of the Dorfman Brothers he's like he was
worried seeing me in Nashville uh about
my mental health a little bit too I
guess it it was this weird thing where
it's like after I said like no there was
a lot of people coming out of the
woodwork being like that's was pretty
worried about you like far as like
kind of things I'm talking about on
stage you know uh maybe doing
psychedelics and things a little too
much you know like talking about drugs
too much on stage and then I kind of
analyze that too I'm like oh yeah it's
like it's not that I was going to become
some [__] addict but the reason I was
trying to do that stuff more is just to
have an escape just to like that's the
only way I could shut my brain off from
like being in work mode so it it was a
it was a weird week I felt embarrassed
you know telling people that I needed
time off I don't know it was like
emasculating almost I I can understand
that yeah yeah that's that old old
[__] you know grind whatever M dude
mental walk it off totally you can't cry
you're not hurt just [__] walk shut
up and walk it off exactly yeah put your
head down and work you just push past it
when did when you made that shift and
finally accepted it did you start to
feel different At first I felt really
like embarrassed and weird and and it's
funny I'm a huge mental health Advocate
and talk about it all the time in the
podcast dude I just had to reschedule a
weekend in Illinois because I had to go
have another back procedure and I was so
worried I had never like I've missed the
weekend but only because of flights
canceled and didn't make it I've never
ever shut a whole weekend down and had
to reschedule for health stuff for well
that's not true actually I was
headlining the Brea Improv and collapsed
in the shower with kidney stones the
first night I was ever going to headline
I had to call him like I I am not I had
to call them from the hospital like I am
just FaceTiming you from the hospital
let you know right um but this was the
first time and I was so worried everyone
was going to be P they couldn't have
been nicer it it they couldn't have been
nicer they get it they get it that was
my experience too and it's like I had
this weird thing in my head where it's
like I'm advocating for everybody else's
mental health but not taking care of
ourselves not taking like and uh and
that also felt weird too like I I
started feeling more like a hypocrite
where I'm like oh I want you to take
care yourself but I'm tougher than that
I don't [__] need that I I'll keep
grinding and then but yeah but then the
fans like they were like yeah man like
you're always telling us to do these
things in our lives how shitty would we
be if we didn't give you that same Grace
and it was really touching actually and
just like everybody being cool and then
now that it's settled in and now that I
have like I'm not going to be doing all
these dates next year I'm still going to
be working plenty on the podcast but
then I'm just going to be working like
what feels like a light 40 to 50 hours
MH
I feel like this crazy weight was lifted
I feel so much happier and uh and more
creative I feel like the most creative I
felt in well because you have time to be
creative now you're not just in this
regimented schedule of we got to get on
here fly there get on this car go to
this place go to that you know you have
time to be creative I you ever do
mantras in the morning like wake up and
repeat phrases to get your mind set no
should I I Journal I write a lot you
know I do that but I don't wake up and
my my Mantra every morning is like come
on Stella get up let's go come on we got
to get to school girl that's that's my
mon every morning I I would do like what
do you call it like giving yourself
intentions for the day yeah and it did
it was effective but also looking back
kind of sad where it's like I would have
these Mon and one of them was like I
would literally tell myself I was a
robot like you're you're a machine
you're a robot like you can power
through you can outwork anybody like all
these crazy things and I put myself in
that mode and I would and I would go
into that mode but then it was very
regimented I was able to accomplish a
lot but I had to have like basically no
emotions and and then just no time for
like reflection creativity just like
nope I'm going to do this for two hours
then I'm going to have a 15-minute lunch
then I'm going to do this I'm going to
eat this kind of thing because it's
light it's not going to make me sleepy
uh on this plane I should be able to get
two hours I mean so
regimented and after a while I'm like
that's not a [__] good way to live
like what am I doing like I got into all
this because it's fun yes and now I've
become this uh machine that is trying to
create fun for others while not having
fun myself and I'm like that is [__]
crazy I'm a big uh that's a big [__] up
of mine too is taking care being a
people pleaser taking care of everybody
else and yep I'll do that for you I'll
do that for you yeah yeah yeah and then
I don't take care of myself isn't it or
they won't do what you know what I'm
saying like reoc yeah the reciprocation
I'm like it's that's tough there was
some oh like Warren Buffett it's like
that guy I've been fascinated with him
forever and I would read like quotes of
his for a while and years ago I read
something about him saying and other
people have said this but how no is the
most powerful word you can use and that
he said like the most successful people
he has ever kind of worked around and
met are people who are really good at
saying no people really good at like
nope this is what I can handle this is
what I'm good at this is what I'm doing
boundaries boundaries get away from me
with everything else it's great advice
Sora taught me that a while ago there's
power in no because I was like I called
him up like go I want your advice on
this I don't remember what was years ago
I'm like did and he goes you know what
say no you I can tell you want to say no
and you're only saying yes because you
think you there won't be another
opportunity if I say yeah fear of
everything you know um and just always
in that like um survival mode survival I
got to say yes cuz God forbid where am I
going to get another $1,500 opportunity
in the next month or whatever you know
so and then when he said that to me
there's power and no and it wasn't just
saying no to bad deals it's also saying
no to overextending yourself and doing
all these things it's it's a great
advice for mental health yeah I it I it
took me till I was 46 to really figure
that one out I'm 50 and I still don't
have it figured out bro but you you you
get habit habitualized I think in like I
don't know if you well I don't I
shouldn't assume you do this but I do
this and I imagine do this where you
kind of internally maybe think of
yourself as Ryan from 10 years ago 15
years ago 20 years ago not Ryan today
because like today you're a very
established figure in the comedy
community you have a very successful
podcast uh very successful standup like
people starting off with I would love to
be Ryan sickler like you are a known
figure but you probably think of
yourself as the guy the 16-year-old that
has no parents and has no [__] income
and no Outlook on life and has no idea
what the [__] he's going to do panic
panic panic yeah that's where I'm at
yeah is isn't a crazy thing we do to
ourselves yes I have yet to like just
take a deep breath and be like all right
you know so I try to practice that too
like hey tomorrow we're fine everybody
wants to focus on today today we're good
but also tomorrow we're going to be good
too yeah no matter what happens today
when we wake up tomorrow that day is
also going to be just fine yep cuz we're
SI sitting right now where but I
couldn't think that before you know what
that's like I I I lived in my car for a
while I could not say hey today's good
and tomorrow is also going to be okay so
for me that's Leaps and Bounds
Improvement you know totally yeah and
I'm saying this stuff now but I still
have those days too like right now I
feel good but you know a week from now I
could be I mean my wife she's such a
saint that way but Lindsay will also
openly tell people like oh yeah he's
crazy as [__] it's like you like live
with him like he's a [__] Maniac like
just all over the place and I'm working
on it but it's like off a day like this
today and then a week from now I I might
be like telling her I'm like it's all
going away we're GNA [__] lose
everything like
we she doesn't even get rattled anymore
when I say she like that she's like she
all right maybe you're hungry go through
probably a little
tired let's pull it together dude thank
you for doing this episode this has been
very very very insightful um your first
time here on this podcast so I ask
everybody yeah after whatever we've
talked about it's interesting because
you had that High School shift too uh
advice you'd give to your 16-year-old
self oh man uh what I would tell my my
16 wear sneers and get off those
[__] roller blades stop trying
to burn everything stop trying to blow
[__] up but I would I would tell I'm
like things are going to get a lot
better like you're going to be okay like
you're a [__] angry dude right now
like a very constructive guy but I'm
like I know you can't see it but there's
going to be a path for you and you're
going to be fine like you're going to be
okay so just ease up that's great advice
and your stepmom's gonna die of cancer
when you're about 30 and you're just
gonna be
fine she's gonna be gone she's gonna be
dead and you're gonna be
okay dude this is a great episode please
again plug promote all of it
uh uh yeah so if you just um go to you
can find time suck if you want uh you
know to I try to make learning fun you
can learn about you know various Cults
uh historical figures historical moments
or if you like uh campfire ghost stories
I got a bunch of them with scared to
death or you can find a bunch of my
stuff online standup wise including uh
trying to get better on YouTube hell
yeah thank you for doing this for real
yeah as always Ryan sikler Ryan sickler
on all social media we'll talk to youall
next
[Music]
[Applause]
week